another week brings us another
action-packed episode of the mcu's
newest television show
let's take a look at where the falcon in
the winter soldier leaves us
at the end of its third episode shortly
after power broker opens we see just how
far bucky is willing to go to pursue the
flag smashers and find the super soldier
serum he's willing to break his old
nemesis
baron zemo out of prison much to sam's
surprise and disapproval
not only that but we learned quite a bit
more about zemo than we ever had before
not only does he come from an incredibly
wealthy family but just like in the
marvel comics he's also a baron a detail
fans have been wondering about since his
mcu introduction in 2014.
i'm a baronson my family was royalty
until your friends destroyed my country
additionally fans get the first look at
zemo's famous purple mask when he dons
it at the end of the trio's trip to
madrapore
located in southeast asia magipore is a
recognizable locale from the pages of
marvel comics often associated with the
x-men
namely wolverine zemo sam and bucky
visit the country to get information
from
selby one of zemo's underworld contacts
the nation is characterized as a lawless
cutthroat area full of crime
thieves and otherwise sketchy characters
this is why the trio has to play their
parts carefully with sam taking on the
identity
of another marvel comics character
smiling tiger bucky meanwhile slips back
into his winter soldier alias
acting as zemo's mind-controlled muscle
their cover is eventually blown when sam
is forced to take a phone call from his
sister
sarah and put it on speakers so the
entire room can hear sarah calls him by
his real name prompting selby to order
her men to attack
but before her crew can act someone from
outside fires a bullet that kills selby
instead
sending sam bucky and zemo on the run
through the streets of madrapore with a
bounty on their heads
alerted to the price on our heroes heads
the people of magipore are on high alert
and wastes no time coming after sam
bucky and zemo
the trio seems done for but they're
saved in the nick of time by former
shield agent sharon carter who reveals
what she's been up to since her last mcu
appearance in captain america
civil war in the 2016 film she's shown
stealing both
sam's falcon wings and the captain
america shield for steve rogers from the
united states government they'd been
confiscated since the heroes were
branded criminals for choosing not to
sign the sokovia accords for helping
them sharon was labeled an enemy of the
state and had no choice but to escape
the us
her travels led her to madrapore where
she's built an impressive life for
herself
sharon goes above and beyond to help sam
bucky and zemo find their next target
the man responsible for creating the new
super soldier serum and then helps them
stay alive long enough to flee madrapore
however rather than join them for the
next stop on their quest sharon decides
to stay put
while sam promised to get her pardoned
upon the mission's completion until it
goes through she's still a wanted
fugitive
sharon carter has a long history in the
comics as an ally of captain america but
her time in madripore may have led her
to prioritize her own well-being
we'll have to see whether she pops up
again as a friend or foe to bucky or sam
so far luck hasn't been on sam and
bucky's side when it comes to finding
carly morgenthau and the rest of the
flag smashers
the next best thing would be to find
who's responsible for the return of the
super soldier serum something that zemo
manages to uncover during his
negotiations with selby
before she's killed she tells them that
the person producing it is named dr
wilfred nagel a scientist who works for
the mysterious power broker
and has gone to horrendous lengths to
replicate dr erskine's formula
thanks to sharon's connections in
madrapore's underworld she discovers his
secret lab's location hidden inside a
series of shipping containers
as dr nagel explains to sam bucky and
zemo after they enter his lab hydra
recruited him to revitalize the
long dormant winter soldier program
however his career faced a shift
when hydra collapsed and he then went to
work with the cia
during that time dr nagel used the blood
samples of unsung super soldier isaiah
bradley to successfully recreate and
further refine the serum unfortunately
for him he disappeared in thanos
infamous snap returning five years later
to find the cia
no longer had use for his research bent
on completing his work dr nagel came to
madripore with none other than the power
broker as his financial backer before
sam and bucky can get any more
information out of dr nagle zemo shoots
and
kills him there's good and bad that
comes out of dr nagle's death the good
is that he can't make any more super
soldier serum and
unless someone else also knows how to
create it sam bucky and zemo now have
something of an edge in their mission
the bad of course is that they won't get
any more answers or leads from the
scientist
while our heroes attempt to crack the
case of these super soldier serums
re-emergents we learn a bit more about
flag smashers figurehead carly
morgenthau it's revealed that she has a
strong connection to someone she refers
to as mama dania madini who dies toward
the end of the episode from tuberculosis
carly uses this loss to fuel her mission
of helping those whose lives have been
disrupted and who've been displaced
since half the world's population
returned from the blip
it sounds like a noble enough cause but
her methods are questionable at best
not only did carly steal all of the
power broker's remaining doses of super
soldier serum but she and the flag
smashers are also now using it to spread
chaos wherever they go
even after stripping a global
repatriation council shelter of its
stockpiled resources carly uses a car
bomb to send the building up in flames
while the grc's people are still inside
she claims that doing so is the only way
to get those opposed to the flag
smashers cause to listen but even
carly's ally dovich is taken aback by
this new level of violence
viewers don't see much of john walker
this week but what they do get is quite
revealing
he's first shown infiltrating a
suspected flagsmasher's refuge and
almost
immediately losing his cool on the man
who owns the building walker attempts to
use his status as captain america to
threaten him
going as far as using physical force to
interrogate him and when it doesn't work
walker fumes later on we see walker
speak with lamar hoskins about their
plan to stop the anarchist group
lamar if we get the job done do you
really think they're going to sweat us
on the how
it doesn't take an extensive knowledge
of the world of marvel to know that an
attitude like this is grossly
unbefitting of anyone calling themselves
captain america
even without seeing this exchange bucky
is well aware of this and when he
sam and zemo are on the plane leaving
majorpoor bucky tells sam he's going to
take steve's shield from walker once
their mission is over
the shield means too much to bucky to
see its importance and the legacy behind
it desecrated while it's in walker's
hands
bucky knows the world needs a new
captain america but not the one it has
right now
and he goes on to imply that he'd take
the title if need be
however sam now realizes he regrets
giving up the shield
and also wants to get it back to destroy
it neither of these two agree on what
should be done with a shield but they
both know it can't stay in walker's
hands
of course if you're looking to the comic
books for your answer you're out of luck
both the falcon and the winter soldier
have spent time using the name captain
america and carrying his signature
shield
bucky took the mantle first in 2008's
captain america vol
3 number 34 while sam started his stint
as captain america a few years later
in 2014's captain america volume 7
number 25.
at this point it's anybody's guess as to
which one of these two will wield the
shield by the series
end if either of them do so at all
having evaded the bounty on their heads
in madrapor sam bucky and zemo soon head
to latvia to learn more about carly's
connection to the late donya madani the
trio arrived there safely but bucky can
tell that something isn't quite right
he splits off from his allies and begins
retracing their steps
discovering tracking fobs that lead into
a nearby alley he reaches the end of the
fob's trail calling out for their owner
to reveal themselves in a magnificent
twist dura malaji member io emerges
explaining that she followed them to
latvia for zemo the connections between
zemo bucky and the entire nation of
wakanda date back to captain america
civil war
zemo was directly responsible for the
death of the wakandan king t'chaka
making him a target for the then prince
t'challa who sought revenge but zemo
pinned the bombing on bucky
leading him and the black panther to
clash thankfully by the end of the film
the plot came to light and t'challa
learned of zemo's treachery
the baron went to jail and bucky went to
live in wakanda to begin rehabilitating
himself after his time living as the
brainwashed winter soldier
it's hard to blame the wakandan people
for wanting zemo locked up once again
it'll be very intriguing to see how
wakanda and its people factor into the
next three episodes of the falcon and
the winter soldier now that they've made
their presence known
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite comic book heroes and
villains are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single
[Music]
one